seit dieser woche hat sie gerne über
eine millionen subscriber auf youtube
und das sind zwar nur zahlen aber für
uns ist es trotzdem ein wichtiger
meilenstein in unserer geschichte
und wir dachten dass wir das als anlass
nehmen um euch mal zu erzählen wie sie
german eigentlich entstanden ist und was
ja die ganze geschichte dahinter ist
denn das haben wir auf diesem kanal noch
nie erzählt und das machen wir heute los
gehts halt hier ein trank wer hier
investiert die auf münster fest german
lassen hatte hello to the people
wie geht es ihnen gut wie alle erste
folge von germanys 2000 im jahre 2006
entstanden
ich habe gearbeitet als leiter eine
menge energie an einem gymnasium und ein
freund von uns ist den gegnern gefahren
er wollte dort eine befreundete familie
besuchen und er erzählte uns dass zwei
mädchen in dieser familie versuchen
deutsch zu lernen und dann sagte ich
hätte es witzig wenn sie ihr für diese
mädchen ein video produzieren mit dem
wir ihnen zeigen dass wir uns freuen
dass sie deutschland und dass wir das
unterstützen wollen guten tag
wie der 10 hallo hallo und wir haben uns
ein gag ausgedacht ausgedacht wir
dachten wir nehmen ein mikrofon und eine
kamera gen in die start und rufen den
menschen hallo zu und wir haben gehofft
dass sie damit nicht so ganz fertig
werden mit dieser spontanen
ungewöhnlichen situation und das sie uns
interessante und lustige reaktionen
liefern und genauso ist das dann auch
gekommen
guten tag sagt sie und in dem gleichen
jahr ist ein youtube auf den markt
gekommen und ich habe dieses video als
test hochgeladen und das video ist
ziemlich populär geworden und später
haben wir diese idee immer wieder
umgesetzt
im rahmen der arbeit der medien und gehe
als eine übung die sehr gerne gemacht
haben geht es ihnen schlecht warum wir
schlecht was los ist dass der turm
hallo und herzlich willkommen zu unserem
golf sprachkurs
so jetzt stehen wir hier schon vor dem
rewe supermärkte und wir wollen mal
gucken wie es heute drinnen aussieht
mein allererster auftritt bei isar
germany das war 2008
janisch und ich haben vor einem
supermarkt gedreht und wir haben quasi
menschen aufgelauert also wir haben uns
ein bisschen versteckt also was ist und
heute einkauft zwei baguettes croissants
zum frühstück mittagessen schon
gefrühstückt und was ja wie kreativ und
man muss wissen dass wir mit kari davor
beim offenen kanal eine musiksendung
ziemlich lange produziert haben und so
hat er die zu der zeit schon sie viele
erfahrungen vor der kamera und
dementsprechend energisch und lustig hat
sie diese episode geleitet hallo was
haben sie denn heute eingekauft warum
wollen sie das wissen wir machen einen
deutsch sprachkurs und heute ist das
thema einkaufen
[Musik]
hallo liebe fans von easy german wir
sind heute in der münsteraner innenstadt
und werden die leute zu ihren berufen
befragen es gibt ja viele berufe ja also
das erste video in dem ich auftauche ich
weiß noch dass war damals einfach in der
art wie janisch und ich mein papa und
ich zeit miteinander verbracht haben wir
sind einfach rausgegangen was haben
leute interviewt das war ja noch
ziemlich neue das ganze projekt und ich
habe mich damals für das thema berufe
interessiert weil ich einen podcast
tatsächlich zum thema berufe machen
wollte und wir sind einfach losgedüst
also da war nicht viel planung dabei das
ist schon jemand aufgeschnitten
angeschnitten
und was machen sie von beruf rentner
das haben sie früher gearbeitet ich habe
kaffeemaschinen repariert das ist der
beste moment dieser typ der
kaffeemaschinen sein leben lang
repariert hat also wir sind ja quasi
seelenverwandte ja also beides café
enthusiasten und dann haben wir auch
noch mehr oder weniger das gleiche shirt
an diese szene ist einfach so großartig
und es gab auch so coole kommentare dazu
also dafür liebe ich dieses video
wirklich bis heute dafür muss aber
regelmäßig auch branche ich komme da
inka beträgt
[Musik]
hallo liebes internet hallo liebe
freunde von easy german wir sind heute
in keiner stadt ganz im norden von
deutschland hinter mir beginnt bereits
die ostsee eine besonders schöne
erinnerung habe ich als ich manuell in
kiel besucht habe manuell hat dort
tatsächlich im internet produktion
studieren
medienproduktion aber es war
medienproduktion im internet mit diese
betonung also manuell kann man sagen
dass als sehr arbeitet tatsächlich in
dem beruf den er gelernt hat und
studiert hat also mein allergrößter
wunsch wäre dass wir jetzt noch schön
winter haben mindestens drei tage lang
das wäre ein unmittelbar direkt in den
frühling kehren und das ist die stärkste
erinnerung an dieses video ist dass wir
drei oder vier stunden gedreht haben in
dieser eisigen kälte und dann eine kurze
pause gemacht haben in einem café und
uns das material angeguckt haben und die
funkstrecke die das drahtlose micro
betrieben hat war einfach aus die ganze
zeit und wir hatten keinen ton und sowas
muss jeder produzent jeder kameramann
ihr da haust erlebt irgendwann früher
oder später lebt so eine katastrophe das
verschont kleinen und es war aber hart
wegen der kälte wegen der länge es war
schon hart und ich war nur froh dass
manuell sehr gelassen und cool reagiert
hat also er hat nicht geweint er hat
mich nicht geschlagen während die kamera
nicht sondern er hat gesagt papa dann
wir gehen kurz nach hause und dann gehen
wir noch mal los und das haben wir dann
auch getan und dann haben wir noch vier
stunden weiter gefüllt und am ende ist
eine sehr schöne episode geworden stell
dir vor du rettest morgen geburtstag was
würdest du dir wünschen dass also ich
hab irgendwann geburtstag aber soll ich
schon mir fast gedacht ja aber was ich
mir wünsche dass der tempel von
playmobil welcher töpfl der von den
klägern
hallo wir sind heute in berlin für eine
neue folge dc german wir werden jetzt
durch sommerliche berlin spazieren und
die leute fragen was wir in dieser stadt
lieben oder auch waffen oder stoffen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
2013 damals wohnte ich schon in berlin
und easy kam zu besuch nach berlin und
wenn wir uns verabredet zum drehen und
ich glaube dass ich sie überzeugt habe
dass ich die kamera mache und sie vor
die kamera geht ich glaube sie war so
ein bisschen zögerlich und hat es dann
einmal gemacht und dann haben wir
zusammen gedreht und es ist eine sehr
schöne episode geworden und
wahrscheinlich einer der ersten aus
berlin und die erste episode mit easy
und du magst du berlin
was ist besonders schön an berlin
der sommer ja ja da war auch gerade
sommer das war die erste folge die ich
komplett andere moderiert habe 2013 im
mai im mai juni und das war eine gute
erfahrung aber irgendwie komisch weil es
war das erste mal dass ich allein auf
die straße gegangen bin mit manuel und
alle leute ansprechen musste und ein
bisschen überwindung hat das natürliche
kostet aber es war sehr lustig ich weiß
noch der was man mir den ganzen tag
erzählt hat und sagt dann ein wenn es
nach wir haben ja jetzt schon 20
interviews mannes fragt doch jetzt man
sagt ja immer wir brauchen mehr material
wir brauchen dort mindestens doppelt so
viel wie wir nutzen wollen
wir brauchen mehr material mehr material
was mögen sie an berlin
alles was besonders weil diese viel
falsche freunde in kreuzberg total toll
na ja und wir sind wir sind ziemlich
viel gelaufen das weiß ich noch weil ich
sehe dass jetzt auch in dem video
wir sind ja in total unterschiedlichen
stadtteilen
ich glaube dann richtig lange gedreht
richtig viel material gesammelt
hallo liebe leute und herzlich
willkommen zurück banken sie die
zuschauer herzlich willkommen zurück bei
einer neuen episode ist die german hallo
liebe zuschauer herzlich willkommen
zurück bei diesem bösen zurück weite wie
sie heutzutage klingt das vielleicht
normal dass man sagt youtube ist mein
beruf oder ja ihr wisst wahrscheinlich
dass wir das hauptberuflich machen wie
sie dürfen aber damals also ganz am
anfang war das für mich überhaupt keine
option oder idee ich wusste ehrlich
gesagt nicht mal dass es so einen beruf
gibt wie youtuber zu sein und das alles
hat sich ein bisschen im jahr 2013/2014
geändert als wir ja immer mehr zuschauer
hatte
und irgendwann hat uns youtube
geschrieben und hat gesagt hey ihr habt
da einen ganz guten kanal aber ihr
solltet das mal professionell machen und
wir helfen euch dabei glaubst du dass es
in deutschland schwieriger ist freunde
zu finden als in anderen ländern
nein glaube ich nicht wie ist dann der
typische deutsche vielleicht ein
bisschen reserviert dass man auf den
ersten blick denkt oh gott dies aber
arrogant oder so und dann im jahr bin
ich irgendwann immer mehr diese
verrückte idee entwickelt hey das könnte
klappen wenn wir lange genug beständig
genug an diesem projekt arbeiten dann
könnte das vielleicht tatsächlich
irgendwann unser beruf sein das ist
natürlich am anfang ein bisschen
utopisch weil wir haben mit diesem
projekt zwar ein bisschen geld verdient
über google adsense aber ja wenn man
irgendwie 100 oder 200 euro im monat
verdient und das über einen sehr langen
zeitraum dann ist das noch total weit
davon entfernt dass beruflich zu machen
und wir hatten aber die sind dieses
glück dass wir uns über unsere arbeit
das auch so langsam langsam machen
konnten wir haben einfach angefangen
haben gesagt okay wir versuchen es jetzt
wir sind nach berlin gezogen wir haben
angefangen jede woche zwei videos zu
produzieren und wir haben
wirklich jetzt jahre lang durchgehalten
und das mittlerweile bin ich da auch ein
bisschen stolz darauf dass wir das so
durchgezogen haben und was wir uns
dadurch unseren beruf erarbeitet haben
[Musik]
hallo leute herzlich willkommen wir sind
heute wunderschönen norwegen herzlich
willkommen zurück bei sie türmen
wir sind heute in new york nieder und
herzlich willkommen in taiwan
hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen bei easy jammen wir sind
heute in ho chi minh city widmen und das
ist unser easy german meter einige jahre
später haben wir schon angefangen etwas
geld zu verdienen und das erste geld
haben wir in die reisen gesteckt wir
sind auf die weltreise gegangen sind
nach amerika fahren japan nach vietnam
nach mexiko und überall wo wir hinkamen
gab es ganz viele fans von uns
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen zu super easy german heute
aus singapur
hallo leute wir begrüßen euch heute aus
mexiko city und wieso lernst du deutsch
ich möchte nach deutschland zu studieren
und warum nennst du durch deine kleber
die durch sprache und musik und warum
lernst du deutsch weil ich liebe die
deutsche leute diese menschen zu treffen
auf unseren reisen das hat für mich
richtig alles verändert und unserem
projekt und es hat uns irgendwie noch
mehr motivation gegeben aber auch viel
mehr ideen plötzlich hatte ich viel mehr
diese vorstellung okay ich mache diese
videos nicht für irgend so ein diffuses
publikum sondern ganz konkret für diese
person die ich in vietnam getroffen habe
oder für diese menschen die ich in den
usa getroffen habe und so ist das bis
heute dass mir das nun ein richtig gutes
gefühl
[Musik]
ja und das war von null auf unendlich
ich weiß es nicht
wir produzierten diese videos und haben
gehofft wir verdienen da genug geld um
irgendwie zu beleben und plötzlich
merken sie wir werden in der in der
ganzen welt mit begeisterung empfangen
[Musik]
irgendwann haben uns auch immer mehr
leute angeschrieben ich erinnere mich
noch dass sie damals ja viele
kooperationsanfragen hatten viele leute
auch einfach getroffen haben wir haben
teilweise jede woche zwei oder drei
subscriber oder patches von uns
getroffen und das war eine echte
wunderschöne begegnungen und irgendwann
hat uns jeremy geschrieben
und aus dieser begegnung ist dann so
tatsächlich mehr geworden also er hat
uns einen vorschlag gemacht dass wir
zusammen an einer app arbeiten die
erzielung und er hatte schon damals
angefangen und viele ideen gehabt und
irgendwie ja hat uns das begeistert
einmal wegen der idee aber wir haben uns
auch einfach persönlich so gut
verstanden und wir haben damals sogar
ein video zusammen gemacht darüber wie
wir uns kennengelernt haben und
angefangen haben zu arbeiten
vor ungefähr einem jahr habe ich eine e
mail von einem typen namens jeremy
bekommen haben das video based learning
website konzipiert von teilen der union
gibt es kritik in germany
[Musik]
das war auch ein toller moment weil das
bis heute irgendwie unsere arbeit sehr
prägt und auch mir ganz speziell noch
mal eine andere perspektive gegeben hat
so eine app aufzubauen ist tatsächlich
eine andere art von arbeit als die
youtube videos zu machen und das hat
mich einfach total bereichert in der
arbeit und bis heute ergänzen wir uns
sehr gut mit diesen verschiedenen
angeboten videos podcasts und eben zieht
lingen als app
[Musik]
hallo leute heute werden wir euch etwas
typisch deutsches vorstellen warum macht
mit sich so schick also meine freundin
gabriela kann ist es richtig mist gebaut
der ihrem freund betrogen
ich habe aber gesagt nicht erzählt
keinem gabriele keiner menschenseele
früher war das schon immer mein traum
irgendwann mal in einem team zu arbeiten
aber diese idee war lange zeit so weit
weg einfach weil wir mit dem projekt
fast gar kein geld verdient haben also
es war irgendwie utopisch zu glauben
dass wir irgendwann mal genug geld
verdienen könnten um ein team zu haben
tatsächlich und das hat angefangen 2018
wie sie wollte damals was anderes machen
in ihrem leben und haben irgendwie so so
pläne geschmiedet und gehofft ja können
wir das schaffen und wir haben echt wer
damals war das ein großer traum dass wir
einfach dass jemand zu uns kommt und es
war auch dringend nötig weil wir einfach
so wahnsinnig viel arbeit haben also wir
haben schon ich habe glaube ich ja
monatelang einig er bis heute nie
richtig urlaub gemacht in dem sinne dass
wir einfach mal zwei wochen nicht an
arbeit denken wir denken eigentlich
immer rund um die uhr auch am wochenende
immer an euch und das ist zwar ein
schönes gefühl aber es ist auch ein
gutes gefühl irgendwann halt hilfe zu
haben das hat 2018 angefangen als sie
ins team dazu kam
hallo leute wir sind heute in köln
ich habe hier einige jahre gelebt und
werde diese schöne stadt in genau einer
woche verlassen
daher dachte ich zeige ich euch mal ja
ich habe in 2018 im herbst angefangen
vollzeit für easy german zu arbeiten ich
habe vorher schon einige stunden
nebenbei im tutti management gearbeitet
aber es kam dann so dass es immer mehr
arbeit gab
durch die übungen die wir für unsere
mitglieder gemacht haben das forum und
alle kann
die wir betreuen das ja wieder schon
glaube ich schon öfter karriere schon
darüber geredet haben und dann
irgendwann kam es dazu ich hatte selber
auch nicht gerade beruflich verändert
ich hatte schon ein jahr remote also
ortsunabhängig gearbeitet wollte freier
sein kreativer sein
und dann hat das 2008 im herbst
angefangen haben das war die beste
entscheidung überhaupt im zeit im herbst
2008 haben sie riesige redet mit uns zu
arbeiten und dann später auch manuell
und plötzlich merkte ich greven jetzt
ein team wir sind jetzt nicht alleine
sondern wir arbeiten in ein team dann
ist irgendwann justina ist immer war
schon davor ja und justine hat mir darum
mit uns da forschung gearbeitet und
jetzt haben wir seit zwei oder drei
monaten christ dabei der quasi mehr die
arbeit abgenommen hat und sich viel
besser macht als ich das hier gemacht
habe und und wir erwarten sozusagen noch
zwei münzen mehr für uns im team und das
ist tag sollte ich ins weinen dabei weil
das ist unglaublich dass man den
richtigen team mit mit hochbegabten und
hochprofessionellen münchen hat und um
uns herum die uns helfen dieses projekte
noch besser noch schöner noch wirksamer
noch sinnvoller zu machen
2009 10 kam manuel irgendwann mit dieser
podcast idee um die ecke eigentlich
hatte er die idee schon sehr lange aber
er hat dann immer gesagt so ja ja wir
machen das irgendwann ist aber nie was
passiert und ich dachte ja ja wir machen
das irgendwann unser podcast ja das ist
wirklich ein traum der wahr geworden ist
also ich war und bin jahrelanger podcast
fan und hab's wirklich jahre lang immer
gedacht wie cool wäre das wenn easy
german ein podcast hätte wenn man sich
richtig in die sprache vertiefen könnte
mit einem podcast und ich habe sehr
lange einfach drüber nachgedacht und
irgendwann habe ich gesagt kari lasst es
uns machen und hast du lust dieses
projekt mit mir zu starten und diesen
podcast mit mir zu moderieren
[Musik]
hallo manuell hallo kw ich muss sagen
dass ich am anfang gar nicht so richtig
verstanden habe was das jetzt heißt wir
machen einen podcast ich dachte einfach
emanuel ist so begeistert
das wird schon also ich hatte nie einen
zweifel daran dass das was er anfängt
auch gut wird weil er einfach so für
diese idee so sehr im trend
aber gleichzeitig habe ich mir gar keine
vorstellung gemacht wie das mein leben
verändern wird weil jetzt bin ich
tatsächlich eine podcast darin ich
erinnere mich dass carey so reagiert hat
so ja podcast weiß ich nicht ist jetzt
nicht so mein thema aber klar machen wir
warum nicht und ich kann mir das zwar
nicht vorstellen wie du das meinst und
was das dann werden soll aber klar
machen wir einfach und ja für mich das
einfach unglaublich dass das jetzt so
ein großer teil von unserem alltag
geworden ist und von von unserer woche
also wir verbringen viel zeit mit dem
podcasten und mit dem schneiden und mit
allen sachen die dazugehören transkript
und es macht unglaublich viel spaß und
ich kann es nicht glauben dass das jetzt
mein beruf ist also es ist wirklich ein
traum der wahr geworden ist für mich
wirklich
[Musik]
für die zirkus habe ich ganz viele und
ganz große wünsche und vorhaben und zwar
wir bauen jetzt unser team noch aus mit
sehr sehr vielen talentierten menschen
und wir werden einen sehr energischen
und sein team haben das ist mein traum
zum teil haben wir das schon und ich
liebe diese vorstellung der sich mit
diesen münchen an einem tisch sitze und
das hier sagen was auf vielleicht wäre
das gut oder das gut und das gut und das
werden wir dann entwickeln und weiter
ausbauen ja ich freue mich total auf die
zukunft einfach also dieses projekt
funktioniert es macht spaß und wir haben
total viele gute ideen für die zukunft
wir kriegen noch immer viele gute ideen
zugeschickt und ich freue mich einfach
auf das was als nächstes kommt
letztendlich dieses ultimative ziel für
mich ist jemandem der massen zu helfen
jemanden der vorhat eine fremdsprache zu
lernen dass er sich nur zurücklehnen
kann und unsere videos und unsere
materialien genießen und dabei lachen
und gute zeit haben und ohne dass er
merkt lernt er wirksam die sprache und
ich glaube daran es ist möglicherweise
nicht so ganz einfach aber wir werden
das schaffen wir werden
dazu beitragen dass viele viele leute
mehr sprachlich kommunizieren und darauf
diese arbeitsfähig
[Musik]
aber wie schön das alles war das ist ja
unglaublich
und jetzt nach der pandemie fahren sie
wieder
[Gelächter]